guess I've gotten some interesting um
comments from the Larry King episode
that I did interview where people said
that you know that I go you really give
your dad some good apps and you know
it's funny dad you know as I sit here
right now
writing this article or at least memo in
it because that's how I do it
you know I'm giving a lot of thought to
life you know the 40 now I don't know if
you heard and and my kids are getting
older and I'm becoming a more
experienced dad and I think that you
know what we did together really from
1993 from 1992 to 2012 in that 20 year
period obviously most intensely from
what I would say 1996 to 2010 was we
built something together right and and
we spent a lot of time together and it's
you know obviously we got to know each
other in the late 90s and early 2000s
for the first time a lot more because we
didn't get to know each other as well in
the late 70s early 80s 80s because you
just worked so hard and I thank you for
that dad I thank you so much or
sacrificing and I know you did it in a
selfish way because I do it too in a
selfish way I know that it's your
natural state to be an entrepreneur and
build for yourself and that you love
Wine Library heck more than you even
love very close family members but it
doesn't take away from the fact of what
you did and what you established and how
you started the process of our family
being here doesn't take away from the
fact that when your uncle came to
America knurl in the late early 70s it
inspired you to want to go to America
and in a time where many people even
though it should have been so obvious
didn't want to go leave and take the
risk to go to America or somewhere
outside the Soviet Union not only did
you but you brought the whole family
along with you
including your mom and your grandparents
and you came to this country and you
worked so damn hard and and you know
it's funny I think through all our
frictions in building the business it's
super easy and has always been super
easy for me to focus on how we're
different and what I don't agree on but
I've been noticing a trend especially
maybe because I don't see you every day
like I used to and I'm not around as
much on an everyday basis with you but
it's been interesting to me over the
last 24 months 36 months to start being
more in tune than ever with not our
differences but our similarities you
know it's funny I always talk about I
wish there was content and dailyvee and
all this stuff going on when I was in my
20s and 30s and I think what would be
really interesting is if I did a mash-up
right now it would show that back in the
day in the late 90s early 2000s I really
thought that I was 90% mom and 10% you
and that's really just because I didn't
know you as well bad and really because
I didn't know myself as well and so it's
funny to me
as I'm sitting here kind of like talking
to you and and talking it out it's funny
to me to recognize how much more similar
I am to you then I realized how much
we're now officially today I feel like
maybe I'm even 50/50 geez go figure
and you know and I just want you to know
how much you mean to me and
and and even though I think for a long
time in my 20s and 30s I spent a lot of
time focusing on what I didn't love as
much or how we were different or what I
was going to show you that my own ego
and my own pride was so scared for the
narrative to be that you're the reason I
was successful that you're you know even
to this day dad I know you don't read
the comments on the internet cuz thank
God you don't because it'd be really
scared to see what you would do if you
community managed and I don't think I
have any fans lefty surely wouldn't um
you know he you know you'd find it
interesting how many people in a youtube
comment will say well don't listen to
this guy his he is dad you know had a
liquor store that's why he's successful
I'm so scared of that dad I'm so scared
of that in my teens in my 20s it was the
biggest fear I had and now as those
negative comments or or people that push
back are the far minority I find myself
being passionate to make sure that your
legacy isn't lost and what you did isn't
left behind and it doesn't become the
narrative of just what I've accomplished
without the context of what you
accomplished and how much you helped me
to get there and so once you know that
and I want you to know it now not when
you're 90 or 100 or 130 when you're on
your deathbed but I want you to know it
now of how much you mean to me and how
thankful I am and how much I learned
from the way that you and Mom
gated and how I do think my hard work
and my hustle is my separation from the
marketplace and I know that's a learned
behavior by watching how you did it and
I thank you from the bottom my heart and
I wish you the greatest greatest
father's day today tomorrow the next day
and for the rest of your life and I want
you to know how huge of an impact you
know it's funny at a time where you're
probably because I know I know you won't
say it to me but I know how you roll in
a time where you're starting to actually
recognize the differences between us and
the things that I'm able to accomplish
on my own DNA and my own skills and the
separation that it has from you
I find myself pulling closer to the
things that you did enable and create
and dictate and frame up and bring to me
and so I thought it was a good time to
say hey I love you
you